all right I wanted to show you guys my
Halloween decorations for this year
and then in our house
we have a really creepy
situation going on in here
and this is our hallway
Kim Kardashian's going all out for
Halloween yep the beauty Mogul showed
off her over-the-top spooky decor and
let's just say it's bone chilling I
decided to do like a
skeleton theme
and had these like bones and skeleton
trees made
and I wanted to show you guys these
creepy people that are all having like a
bonfire out here
so then around my
front door I made this skull thing
that's really cool North will you open
the front door
but the most interesting display to look
at the graveyard of hands molded from
her family and friends why not I had a
a molding party and they were all molded
these are like my kids hands
these are my niece and nephew's hands
you can see some of our friends hands I
did everyone that we know
and that wanted to come over for a
little
hand mold
you can see mine when I had the nails on
and then you can also see
my chefs
they put up a fake knife in there I just
love this that we'll have these I
definitely wanted a more tonal palette
this year and if you thought that was it
just wait until you see the inside we
have a really creepy
situation going on in here
foreign
and it's like mummies and
all of this
super scary
creepy hallway with my Tyrell at the end
my book it's a great look and Kim's not
the only one in the Halloween spirit
while she was giving a tour you can hear
her kids getting into the spooky season
Vibes in the Next Room
I don't know what they're watching in
there but
it really sounds like a horror film now
Kim's no stranger to being a big
Halloween gal
why not Ashley told us back in 2008 it's
one of her favorite holidays
nerds Nerds candy I don't do the chalk
good on Halloween for some reason I feel
like it melts and
um
I remember one my birthday's near
Halloween so I'd always have my birthday
slash Halloween party together and I
would have this big jar of like gummy
worms and you'd have to guess how many
were in and then you get the whole jar
and they were my favorite so I would
always tell my best friend how many were
in there because I knew the number and
I'd be like I'll split it with you if I
tell you what it is and guess the
clothes
always would no one ever caught on
[Music]